hi my name is Gustav my coworkers  Stephanie loves slots everyday she talks  about slot there's three different  species of sloths loved sloths they're  just like the greatest animal and I  think so me being the nice guy that I am  I reached out to the wildlife Learning  Center and asked if they had a slot that  we could borrow for a couple of hours so  that we can surprise Stephanie with her  favorite animal  you  and  this way hi everybody  sauce slob  are you serious no we talking about this  all the time I'm going to one day get in  fear a lot of convincing a lot of phone  calls the greatest day of my life oh my  god someone someone called my girlfriend  oh my god  you stop you're my best friend in the  world if you ever need a kidney I am sue  oh my god  I don't want to give final thoughts  because that means it's over and I don't  want it to be over this is the greatest  experience of my life